So this is the solution for our ROB timing quiz. The first part,
we were asked when does this multiplication instruction issue, execute, write,
and commit. This instruction will issue in the second cycle.
The reason for that is that we have still two multiply divide reservation
stations. This is using the first one, we can use the second one here so
we can actually issue in the second cycle. So the correct answer here is two for
issue. For execution, we are using R5 and R6.
That doesn't depend on R2, so we can actually begin execution right after
we issue in cycle three. The multiplication will take two cycles to execute so
it's executing in cycles three and four. It's going to try and
write the result in cycle five. And now when does it commit? It commits when it
has both written the result and when all previous instructions have committed.
The previous instruction commit is, had happening later. So,
we will commit in cycle eight, right after the first instruction has committed.